we start off with a great uh few
episodes this season what was your
reaction when you read through the
entire season what are we in for the
rest of season four
it's uh really
boring
i was not impressed with any of the
writing um it's a mess it doesn't make
any sense it's terrible we didn't did we
get ours we got all
a lot of our scripts this time like in
the beginning which was really nice
because sometimes you're getting them
during yeah it was it was a wild ride
you've broken everything
suffering
is almost
at an end
it also was shot over a couple of years
because of covid we shot in lithuania
which was an incredible experience
the people there are
amazing i think people are going to
really fall in love with nico who plays
ziri
he's wonderful and and i think that the
kids are they're not
so much kids anymore the young people
are are fantastic i think that it's all
woven together really beautifully and
still has that that stranger things
heart you know everything is driven by
love and survival yeah i was just exci i
was just so excited that you know
everything was just so much more uh than
it ever had been i mean uh and then also
i was really thrilled to be
in the show more than i had ever been
and get to work and be like a comedy
action duo
with winona i mean and like you know the
whole thing felt like i mean that it was
like leia and then jewish lando
calrissian or human chewbacca take your
pick
uh going to boston
going to bust han out so like you know
the way human chewy
murray is human chewy or jewish lando
uh yeah it just was like
it was like a thrill ride and it really
started with the reading of scrip the
scripts and carried over
into the shooting you know i mean yeah i
mean like shooting in lithuania yeah it
was amazing you know we were used to
being uh where we are when we shoot it
in the states and
to get to be
in a foreign country going on this wild
adventure to rescue our friend
um and and and at this point for uh me
to feel like as the character that i
have friends you know it was just uh
it's an amazing development to
uh to take part
[Music]
hopper's alive and has had quite the uh
like the escape moment what was it like
shooting all that stuff really serious
action scene running through the snow
what looked like barefoot although i'm
not were you actually barefoot
yes i was in a lot of it yeah it was
particularly brutal i wasn't like eating
a lot because there's uh i know i was
worried about there's also like it was
like 20 below certain nights um and then
i ran through the snow barefoot a lot
because he has to take off those chains
and he can't put his shoes back on
because he's caught in a melee thing
yeah but you know as you know he gets
captured again thrown back in he has to
figure out a way to escape again after
that huge scene with the pit and the
demogorgon which of course you know
about that big fight that's incredible
that's like my favorite part in the
whole movie
i was convinced i was put here for some
other reason
maybe i can still help
[Music]
even if it's the last thing i do
we've expanded the world outside of just
hawkins even outside of the upside down
even though we are seeing more of the
upside down i mean in these last few
episodes are we going to see the world
expand
even more
are we going to see it expand even
broader into the next season
the idea of this season was to get the
gang back together like we're not in
hawkins anymore and hopefully we will be
back in hong kong yeah i mean spreading
that flavor throughout the world it was
very much an aim of uh of this season i
think yeah but like i mean and also just
like at the expansion and location i
think
is uh an extension of of uh emotional
and relationship expansion as well and
so it's just everything really great
everything yeah thank you
everything grows you know everything
grows in all ways in season four people
say hawkins is cursed
[Music]
they're not way off
how does
joyce and murray's relationship continue
to grow and then what is i mean when we
get hopper and joyce reunited what does
that do for their
relationship okay so
i think
i i have this thing and i don't know i
mean we we got to spend some time
together joyce and murray got to spend
some time together last year i mean last
season
and i think the whole
you know alexis death yeah
yeah i like
so i think we have the uh uh our
characters and us have like a a bond and
like a weird like i trust him with all
of this stuff and even and you know it's
interesting and what's so great about
brad is like when we meet him in season
two
with like
you know jonathan and nancy you know
he's kind of just like conspiracy
theorists they're funny yeah
they were investigating they were daniel
ellsberg you know and and so when i say
conspiracy there's
now it's like a
totally different it's almost like a bad
word but i love that that
like it's kind of all at all that's
coming to fruition yeah and and i mean
this guy learned russian
for this right i mean that is something
and i also like
i think that that um so
there is this like i think we went
through so much in season three and
obviously an in
immense
in in unthinkable grief of losing
hopper and also i i always feel that i'm
somewhat responsible because i was the
one who
you know
but also
it's also there to sing that damn song
and i mean in terms of like murray
uh his feelings towards joyce i mean
joyce really
i mean season three
joyce hopper and alexi connected him
back more with the world you know and
showed him
uh you know more of a reason to rejoin
humanity and he
very much keeps that with her and she's
very much but also his connection to
that you were right
about so much i also was right about a
lot of people yeah i want to say one
more thing just about like hopper and
joyce's re re
uniting though just that it's um
it's very cool that hopper's been
protecting her from the first season in
a certain way and the reuniting of
hopper and joyce is very much the joyce
has come to save hopper who is very much
you know
in
trapped in this place and he could not
get out without her help and she does an
extremely brave
thing
and it saves his life and so i think um
it's a really cool way to reunite